c'était la 14e attaque de drone sur Kiev
et selon l'armée ukrainienne la plus
importante sur la capitale depuis le
début de l'invasion
nous avons vu arriver le drone et nous
avons aussi vu le travail de la défense
anti-aérienne mais celui-ci a réussi à
passer et il a frappé fort un drone de
fabrication iranienne dont les pompiers
ramassent les restes
dans la nuit de samedi à dimanche les
soldats de la défense anti-aérienne de
Kiev affirme avoir abattu l'écrasante
majorité des drones corps et envoyé la
Russie
volo dix meilleurs Zelenski a tenu à
leur rendre hommage
aux forces de défense entière yen de
l'Ukraine pour vous les alarmes qui
annoncent les raids aériens sont
différemment que pour la plupart des
gens vous vous devez scruter le ciel
pour détruire les missiles les avions
les hélicoptères et les drones ennemis
vous êtes nos héros mais les quelques
drones qui ont réussi à franchir les
défenses entières ont fait plusieurs
morts et celles et ceux qui ont survécu
sont choqués
à 2h du matin il y a eu des bruits très
forts très effrayants il y avait des
bourdonnements des bourdonnements et des
explosions je ne trouve pas les mots il
n'y a simplement pas de mots la Russie
de son côté affirme que les Occidentaux
jouent avec le feu après l'accord récent
des États-Unis pour délivraisons futures
de chasseurs F7